par an
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et merci de nous
rejoindre pour cette soirée
exceptionnelle sur france 3 cette soirée
consacrée aux élections régionales et
départementales c'est parti pour trois
heures de direct des résultats des
analyses et nos invités
bonsoir jérémy bonsoir elsa bonsoir à
tous je vous présente tout de suite nos
invités avec lesquels nous allons réagir
dès 20h nous vous donnerons avec notre
partenaire ipsos steria le nom du futur
président du conseil régional de
bourgogne franche comté nos invités pour
réagir à ces résultats en plateau
laëtitia martinez vice présidente
socialiste sortante du conseil régional
vous êtes candidate dans le département
de saône et loire également sur ce
plateau jean marie sermier député
les républicains du jura candidat dans
votre département du jura est à vos
côtés
dominique bourgois du rassemblement
national candidat vous en côte d'or
voilà sur ce plateau vous l'avez compris
nous allons parler des régionales mais
nous allons aussi évoqué bien sûr tout
au long de la soirée est les élections
départementales et ce sera avec 4e série
et gabrielle talon bonsoir à tous les
deux bonsoir elsa bonsoir à tous en
effet gabrielle talon et moi même nous
allons nous concentrer exclusivement sur
les résultats des élections
départementales dans les huit
départements que compte notre grande
région bourgogne franche comté et nous
ferons en duplex dans les huit villes
préfectures de notre région avec nos
journalistes mais également avec eux des
invités à les candidats tête d'affiche
de ces départements talent et puis il y
aura également et bien des reportages
comme un besoin faux dijon ou encore
jouanny l'enjeu de ces élections
départementales est relativement simple
est ce qu'il ya des départements qui
vont basculer de droite à gauche ou de
gauche à droite
actuellement la droite détient six
départements sur les huit que compte la
france compte la bourgogne franche comté
et 3 sont à gauche ps ou divers gauche
et puis à surveiller également bien sûr
à savoir s'il va y avoir des binômes du
rassemblement national qui seront élus
ce soir dans des cantons à tout à
l'heure à toute à leur merci bon
et catherine alors elsa le fait marquant
à vous donner les résultats et la
première estimation d'ipsos osteria pour
la bourgogne franche comté le fait
marquant c'est l'abstention encore très
forte ce dimanche elle a légèrement
baissé par rapport à dimanche dernier
vous le voyez 62,9 % c'était un peu plus
de 65 % dimanche dernier pour le premier
tour première réaction laëtitia martinez
comment vous expliquez que les électeurs
de bourgogne franche comté et de la
france entière puisque c'est un
phénomène largement partagée n'adhère
pas ne participe pas à ce scrutin mais
je crois qu'on est tous autour de ce
plateau a déploré le taux de
participation de ces de ses deux tours
je crois que les explications elles sont
elles sont multiples il y en a qui sont
spécifiques
aussi je pense à ce scrutin beaucoup sur
je pense la confusion entre les scrutins
départementales et régionales qui sont
différents dans le mode de scrutin dans
les compétences des collectivités
et puis on a quand même constaté c'était
déjà le cas lors du premier tour ça a
été à nouveau le cas sur ce second tour
la mauvaise diffusion très mauvaise
diffusion de la propagande électorale
dans les boîtes aux lettres encore
aujourd'hui quand je faisais le tour des
bureaux de vote
j'ai été interpellé par des électrices
et électeurs qui le dit mais je
comprends pas j'ai reçu au premier tour
puis là j'ai rien reçu au deuxième tour
qu'est-ce qui se passe et là encore une
fois sauf que c'est franchement très
très dommageable pour la peau la
démocratie ce qui se passe de cette
suite dominique pourvoi est ce que vous
êtes responsables comment vous expliquez
vous avez pas réussi à parler à ses
électeurs
manifestement nous ne sommes pas les
seuls puisque le taux de participation
est à peu près le même que dimanche
dernier
malgré tout les rappels qui ont été
faits et dieu sait si sur le terrain
nous avons battu ce rappel ça n'a pas
donné les résultats attendus et je crois
que c'est pareil pour leur centre des
listes jean marie sermier
il ya des causes politiques évidentes
mais il ya une cause technique qui
d'ailleurs est politique c'est ce
sabotage de l'élection par le
gouvernement par la non distribution des
propagandes aujourd'hui un jurassien sur
deux n'a pas reçu dans sa boîte aux
lettres
les matériels des élections on n'était
pas censé savoir pour quelqu'un qui ne
suit pas forcément la politique au
quotidien qu'ils avaient
tours car un deuxième tour qui avait un
deuxième tour des élections régionales
qui n'est pas forcément pour des
élections départementales
c'est quand même quelque chose
extrêmement compliqué donc on aurait
voulu en tous les cas mettre à mal ces
élections on ne s'y serait pas pris
autrement de la part du gouvernement
merci jean marie sermier il est 20
heures dans une poignée de secondes neuf
secondes précisément jérémy chevrillon
on va pouvoir donner le sondage ipsos et
steria estimations notre partenaire
ipsos steria pour la bourgogne franche
comté vous allez voir les scores de ce
second tour apparaître à l'écran etc
marie-guite dufay qui arrive en tête de
ce second tour avec un peu plus de 42 %
des suffrages
marie-guite dufay qui selon toute
vraisemblance sera donc réélue
présidente de la bourgogne franche comté
suivent gilles platret le candidat les
républicains avec 24 4 % des suffrages
quelques points quelques à peine un
point devant julien haut doubs le
candidat du rassemblement national denis
thuriau le candidat de la république en
marche ferme la marche justement avec
moins de 10% des suffrages
il recule donc par rapport à son score
du premier tour et pour aller plus loin
avec eux ces premiers chiffres on va
tout de suite retrouvé
emmanuel rivals en vous le savez ce soir
nos journalistes ont au plus près des
candidats emmanuel rivals 1 qui suit
toute la soirée
marie-guite dufay emmanuel vous êtes en
préfecture j'imagine que on respire oui
c'est une respiration encore assez
calmes seuls denis thuriau est passé il
ya quelques instants marie-guite dufay
la présidente sortante est attendu aux
alentours de 21h dans les mêmes
conditions les mêmes délais que dimanche
dernier alors marie-guite dufay il faut
le dire elle a passé le week-end ou vers
une mise au vert et ne voyait pas de
malice dans mon propos dans le haut
doubs précisément pour retrouver les at
elle dit tout à l'heure de l'humain
après une campagne qu'elle a jugé
extrêmement fatigante extêmement 7000
kilomètres passés au volant à travers
cette grande région pour défendre ses
idées alors ça c'était l'avant vous
l'avez dit maintenant il ya ces premiers
résultats ces premières estimations sans
doute elle même les connais tel elle
était sortie avec 26% contre toute
attente au premier tour elle espérait
secrètement dépassé les 33 % pourquoi
33% 33% et bien pour avoir la majorité
absolue
et quelque part siffler la fin de la
partie il semble qu'elle soit allé au
delà la question qui se pose est c'est
qu'elle pouvait être le comportement des
électeurs de la république en marche
allait-il voter utile entre guillemets
se ranger derrière marie-guite dufay et
donc à gauche où elles et ils voter
comme un copier coller une fois de plus
pour denis thuriau il semble que
beaucoup se soit déporté vers leur
gauche et bien voilà on attend
marie-guite dufay revers 21h pas avant
elle attend les résultats consolidés
avéré pour être présentes ici elle a
toujours procédé de la sorte si beaucoup
emmanuel rivals 1 en direct de la
préfecture on va filer tout de suite à à
besançon dans un hôtel de besançon nous
attend valentin chatelier valentin dans
le qg de julien en double julien ou
double qui réalise ray pour l'instant 23
7% des suffrages 1 valentin j'imagine
que du côté du rassemblement national
c'est la douche froide
sûrement on ne sait pas encore qu'elle
ne sont pas encore descendu en tout cas
on attend julien houle ici dans quelques
minutes pour réagir à ces résultats 23
7%
vous l'avez dit ce serait une grosse
désillusion pour le candidat du parti de
marine le pen
23.7 c'est beaucoup moins que le score
du rassemblement national au second tour
aux dernières élections régionales
elle avait réalisé 32 % des voix une
grosse désillusion car julien houle
n'aurait pas réussi à faire passer son
message
au soir du premier tour il a martelé ces
messages réveillez vous bougez vous aux
urnes at il dit aux abstentionnistes du
rassemblement national visiblement ce
message n'est pas passé il avait aussi
tenté de mobiliser à ses électeurs sur
cette alliance entre les écologistes et
marie-guite dufay
il avait vive
attaquer les écologistes en parlant de
que mes revers en parlant de dingo de
totalitaire pendant ce débat d'entre
deux tours visiblement là non plus cette
stratégie n'a pas fonctionné en tout cas
ici on attend julien en double pour
réagir à ces résultats d'ici quelques
minutes
merci beaucoup valente h atelier et puis
vous le savez on va partir dans un
dernier qg retrouver christophe taris
qui se trouve devant la fédération ait
des républicains à dijon christophe
gilles platret le candidat ait l'air ne
s'est pas montrée encore pour l'instant
oui gilles platret qui a été très
discret aujourd'hui il a voté très tôt
ce matin dès l'ouverture des bureaux de
vote à chalon à 8 heures il a fait
ensuite le tour de quelques bureaux de
sa ville avant de s'enfermer chez lui de
s'isoler en famille à attendre les
résultats à échanger évidemment quelques
informations avec certains de ses
colistiers car tout l'enjeu pour lui qui
avait fini à la troisième place au soir
du premier tour avec 21% des voix
s'étaient de supplanter le rassemblement
national lors de ce deuxième tour ce qui
semble donc être le cas ce soir il
arriverait en seconde position ce qui va
lui permettre de se présenter comme le
premier comme le principal opposant à
marie-guite dufay
au vu de ces résultats les militants ici
était d'ailleurs soulagé satisfait de
voir cette seconde position de gilles
platret arriver mais cela restera tout
de même quand même un échec pour lui et
la droite qui avait 25 sièges au conseil
régional et qu'il devrait donc en perdre
ce soir gilles platret qui est attendu à
dijon d'ici quelques minutes il devrait
s'exprimer non pas depuis la fédération
et depuis un hôtel puis ensuite il se
rendra dans vos locaux à france 3 pour
ses premières réactions
merci beaucoup christophe taris on va
peut-être donner les premiers résultats
et précisé que rémy rebeyrotte le député
la république est en marche de saône et
loire nous a rejoint sur ce plateau
les résultats les premières estimations
notre partenaire ipsos steria pour cette
élection régionales en bourgogne franche
comté la liste de marie-guite dufay
arrive largement en tête des passants
42% des suffrages loin devant gilles
platret les républicains 24,4 puis
julien odoul
le rassemblement national 23,7 denis
thuriau la république en marche est à
9,4 pour cent
laëtitia martinez le score de la semaine
dernière du premier tour était plutôt
inespéré pour votre liste ce soir c'est
une confirmation finalement écouté je
crois qu'on va déjà attendre que les
tendances que vous avez évoqué se
confirme par parler de la totalité des
des dépouillements peut-être d'abord
aussi remercier les électrices et les
électeurs qui sont déplacés pour voter
pour pour marie-guite dufay et si ces
tendances se confirment à ce que votre
sondage la semaine dernière étaient
assez proches des résultats finaux
je crois qu'on constate à la fois le
report de l'intégralité des voix de
gauche et aussi l'affirmation d'un bloc
de gauche 40% au premier tour voilà
absolument donc on a vraiment cette
confirmation c'est cela le sens de ceux
de sotchi fils à ceux des viandes la
gauche aura les mains libres
et si ça se confirme se confirme la
gauche pourra en tout cas mettre en
oeuvre le programme pour laquelle pour
lequel elle a été élue le programme
porté par par marie-guite dufay je crois
que l élément qui me semble important
c'est que quand on est clair et c'est
exactement ce qui a été le cas de
marie-guite dufay qui appelait depuis le
début de sa compagne rassemblement de la
gauche
on voit que cette clarté dans un monde
où les repères se perdent
elle paraît assez essentielle pour
justement pour inciter au vote le
sérieux le travail de cette de cette
campagne a je pense jouer aussi sur ce
qui c'est ce qui n'était encore que ds
qui ne sont encore que des estimations
rémy rebeyrotte voilà ce sont des
tendances mais a priori de nitro est en
baisse de 11,7 à 9,4 comment vous
analysez vous ce résultat on va écouter
nous ne nous faisons pas d'illusions
dans la mesure où un forte abstention
s'était dit en juin quand c'est quand
même par là c'est quand même une vraie
inquiétude pour notre pays la deuxième
chose c'est quand même l'hyper prime aux
sortants mais pas seulement bourgogne
franche comté par tous partent ce soir
je crée si ce soit a priori dans
l'ensemble des régions métropolitaines
les sortants sont réélus
voilà donc si vous voulez y en a une à
l'hyper prime au sortant on l'avait déjà
vu pour les municipales d'ailleurs un
c'est peut-être la caractéristique des
élections période
et finalement c'est à dire il ya une
hyper hyper véritablement prime au
sortant
et puis le vote utile 1 entre les deux
tours le vote utile qui a désiré donc
pas de surprise on constate partout en
bourgogne franche comté comme ailleurs
et donc nous en prenons acte
naturellement c'est un échec pour m nl
macro c'est un échec pas pour le
président de la république
cette année chèque sans aucun doute pour
la majorité dans les régions bien que
nous allons rentrer sans doute quelques
élus dans les régions et les
départements on verra combien je veux
dire nous étions pas du tout représenté
jusqu'ici puisque oui oui vous rêviez en
faiseurs de roi en 2015 nous n'existions
pas donc c'est quand même j'allais dire
c'est quand même une réalité c'est un
nouvel échec d'importation quand même de
la république en marche après les
municipales comment vous l'expliquez ça
je pense qu'on est vraiment dans une
période de crise coville justement enfin
ou varia une prime il ya une hyper prime
aux sortants et donc aux gens déjà
implanté qui à partir de leur
implantation effectivement on construit
y compris d'ailleurs des des solutions
dans le cadre de la crise qu vide et
donc bon voilà enfin je le constate un
certain constat simplement qu'il ya une
hyper prime au sortant
alors la droite républicaine et les
républicains sont particulièrement
implantés notamment en bourgogne franche
comté et pourtant jean marie sermier
vous n'y arrivez toujours pas pour des
élections régionales
écoutez si les chiffres se confirment
moi je voudrais adresser toutes mes
félicitations une manière républicaine à
madame buffet qui a su finalement donc
mobilisés et surtout rassembler
et la gauche et les verts et on va voir
d'ailleurs 6 7 6 7
attelage va fonctionner puisque
aujourd'hui il ya huit élus si je crois
que ces chiffres sont bons qui sont
issus huit élus verts huit élus
communistes voilà donc mon moi je
souhaite que ça réussisse
parce qu'avant les partis politiques ce
qui m'intéresse c'est ma région
la bourgogne et la franche comté mais
force est de constater que il ya eu une
prime effectivement au sortant puisqu'on
constate que a priori les treize
présidents de région sortants serait
réélu avec des scores quelquefois
impressionnant comme laurent wauquiez ou
xavier bertrand au-delà de 50% en tous
les cas ce qui n'est pas le cas chez
nous 5 5% pour laurent wauquiez et 54%
pour de la vie mais revoilà tout à fait
et donc je pense que on a été victime
d'une campagne tronquée tronquée et sans
doute par la crise sanitaire mais je le
répète tronquée également par l'absence
de distribution du matériel électoral de
la propagande
est-ce qu'il peut pas on peut pas
mobiliser un camp quand on est sans
information sur rien et naturellement
les gens qui se sont rendus aux urnes
qui quelquefois ne savais même pas qu'il
y avait un deuxième tour pour les
régionales au dernier moment quand il
n'avait pas préparé d'une manière
efficace au dernier moment ils ont voté
pour la personne la plus connue et on
conteste pas que en termes de notoriété
ce soit madame du fait donc je crois
savoir que j'y travaille manque de
notoriété
c'est une évidence que lie aujourd'hui
personne à droite avait la notoriété de
madame du fait parce qu'elle est
présidente de région depuis un certain
nombre c'est le mandat donc heureusement
qu'elle a une notoriété un peu supérieur
à tous les atouts et les candidats nous
nous étions une liste de reconquête et
je crois que dans les listes de
reconquête faut regarder j'ai quelques
chiffres aussi il me semble que nous
finissons largement en tête des régions
qui étaient susceptibles d'être donc
repris mais la droite elle pouvait
ambitionner quand même de faire un peu
mieux est de même de rang pour gagner
cette région on pouvait essayer de la
gagner effectivement on n'y a vraiment
plus on a fait le travail je crois avec
gilles platret sous sa responsabilité
sous sa houlette et ça ça bien marché ce
qui n'a pas marché c'est qu'on n'a pas
pu faire de campagne
ce quotidien on n'a pas pu rencontrer
des gens d'une façon normale
on n'a pas pu réunir les gens d'une
façon normale dans une campagne
régionale - le juge en marche je fais
des réunions dans tous les cantons
jean marie sermier est-ce que c'est
aussi votre alliance avec debout la
france qui n'a pas fonctionné
absolument je pense même que avec le
recul ça nous a plutôt apporté beaucoup
de points parce que cette alliance a
fait causer dans les médias pendant
quelques jours et je peux vous assurer
qu'on est en sus le terrain où j'en
entendais parler et j'entendais plutôt
des gens qui étaient très satisfaits
qu'on puisse avoir une liste qui soit
claire avec un discours qui est clair ce
qui n'est pas le cas de la liste de
madame buffet je vous le dis je lui
adresse toutes mes félicitations
mais il y aura quand même à gérer lui
conseillers régionaux qui seront issus
des verts 8 conseillers régionaux issus
des partis communistes et çà j'espère
que ça se passera bien mais j'en suis
pas sûr dominique bourgois je vouvoyais
réagir quand on a évoqué l' alliance
avec debout la france oui je pensais
intérieurement en valeur absolue les
airs sont à un score qui est moins
important qu'il n'y paraît parce qu'il
ya précisément cet apport des électeurs
de debout la france est une certitude
qui vous a porté préjudice
alors qu'ils apportaient préjudice
probablement un peu mais comme ça a été
rappelé par l'ensemble des intervenants
c'est une campagne qui a souffert de
l'absence de visibilité de
visibilité des couacs à tous les niveaux
pas de distribution de profession de ces
débats un peu facile ce discours depuis
dimanche dernier les uns les autres
vous nous dites c'est la faute à la
distribution des tracts c'est la faute à
la proximité de l'été les français
préparent leurs vacances les français
ils disent aussi ce soir aux politiques
on en a marre et vous ne vous vont nous
intéresser plus à l'ensemble de la
classe politique maintenant mais bien
sûr c'est multifactoriel
il y à qu'a rappelé qu'il y avait la
situation de la crise qu vides il y a
les couacs répétés sur la propagande et
la campagne il y à l'absence de
visibilité et de lisibilité de ce type
d'élection il ya une culture plus tôt il
ya une absence et je pèse mes mots
ça n'est pas du tout polémique mais il
ya une absence de culture politique en
france des gens ne connaissent pas les
collectivités territoriales ne
connaissent pas les pouvoirs des
collectivités ne savent pas exactement
quels sont les liens qui existent entre
les unes et les autres donc quelque part
quand vous sentez pas responsable en
amont vous sentez pas responsables tout
le monde est responsable
tout le monde ou personne bien sûr qu'il
ya une responsabilité collective
la responsabilité des politiques qui
n'arrivent plus à imprégner qui
n'arrivent plus à un prime ils sont les
électeurs du rassemblement national
aujourd'hui je pense que il ya quelques
milliers qui se sont déplacés comme
dimanche dernier puis en a d'autres qui
sont peut être restés chez eux
en considérant qu'il n'y avait pas
d'intérêt allez voter tout simplement
merci je vous propose qu'on fasse une
petite pause on va tout de suite rejoins
de gabrielle talon et catherine syrie
pour évoquer un autre scrutin puisque
vous le savez aujourd'hui deux scrutins
c'est une première on va parler des
élections départementales ce tabou
catherine merci et zaoui
bonsoir à tous bonsoir à ceux qui nous
rejoignent
concernant les départementales je vous
propose tout de suite d'aller faire un
tour à belfort où nous retrouvons
emilien diaz emilien vous avez peut-être
déjà des résultats
oui bonsoir catherine effectivement
alors vous le savez ici c'est un match à
deux entre la gauche et la droite
l'équation est assez simple dans le
territoire de belfort si la droite veut
conserver sa majorité au conseil
départemental elle doit l'emporter dans
cinq des neuf cantons du département 2
lui sont déjà acquis florian bouquet le
président sortant
s'est imposé au premier tour la semaine
dernière le sénateur cédric terrain lui
est seul candidat dans son canton de
dell il ya donc des cantons clés ici qui
peuvent faire basculer d'un côté ou d'un
autre la majorité les premiers résultats
que nous avons ici donnent la droite en
tête dans les cantons clés de valdoie de
giromagny notamment un resto aussi un
canton important à déterminer celui de
bavilliers mais pour l'instant les
résultats donneraient la droite
al'avantage dans ces cantons clés ici
dans le département du territoire de
belfort
je je je dois je dois donc affirmer ce
que vous venez de dire on va revoir le
résultat de ma ville et je dois affirmer
ce que vous venez dire emilia en effet
sajoo a très très peu
très très peu de voix sur le contour de
bavilliers en fait donc eric oberlé qui
est le rejet excusez moi j'ai du mal de
devoir eric oberlé qui est le maire de
bavilliers équité conseiller
départemental sortant et serait battue
de 0,5 pour cent des voix il serait
battu par le binôme de gauche je vous
propose maintenant d'aller faire un tour
à mâcon n'est ce pas gabriel oui en
saône et loire à la saône et loire qui
avait déjà élu quatre binômes au premier
tour et bien tous ceux des candidats de
la majorité sortante de droite on va
retrouver florence d'ozon sur place
florence il restait il reste 25 cantons
a attribué ce soir et oui sur le papier
le département de la saône et loire
semble acquis à la majorité sortante
vous l'avez dit au lendemain du premier
tour elle a déjà gagné quatre cantons
paray-le-monial givry chauffer ou encore
charolles il pourrait être ce soir leur
joueur au nombre de sept et les binômes
de divers droite faisaient la course en
tête dans 18 des 25 autres cantons à
l'issue de ce premier tour donc c'est un
avantage non négligeable pour andré
accary et ses partenaires du côté de
l'opposition et bien la gauche partait
favorable dans seulement sept cantons
dont cluny
blanzy ou encore au creusot et ailleurs
et bien elle va tenter de s'appuyer sur
une réserve de voix des socialistes
éliminé au premier tour comme à mâcon 2
où comme à hurigny reste une inconnue
gabriel que feront les électeurs du
rassemblement national à qui profiteront
à leur vote
un rassemblement national qui semble ce
soir pas en mesure de s'imposer dans un
des sept cantons où il est encore en
lice merci florence et après la
saône-et-loire direct sur le doubs oui
tout à fait nous allons maintenant au
kursaal à besançon
donc c'est là où sont centralisés tous
les résultats de la ville nous
retrouvons stéphanie et bourgeot or le
doubs c'est le département qui a le
moins voté de la bourgogne franche comté
quelle est l'ambiance malgré tout au
kursaal il ya du monde comme d'habitude
alors il y a un peu plus d'ambiance que
la semaine dernière ça c'est très clair
bien sûr il ya les présidents des
bureaux de vote qui arrivent pour
délivrer leur précieuse enveloppe mais
il est aussi une poignée de militants
qui scrutent attentivement le tableau
géant que vous ne voyez pas il est juste
devant nous là où s'inscrivent petit à
petit les résultats des dépouillements
et qui applaudissent qui ont applaudi
bien sûr tout à l'heure aux résultats
des régionales on va revenir aux
cantonales aucun des 19 cantons du tout
vous le savez n'a été pourvu lors du
premier tour pas même celui de christine
d'aucuns à l'actuel le président ait
l'air et ce malgré un score de plus de
60% dans son fief de mèches la faute à
l'abstention vous l'avez dit qui
l'empêché d'atteindre le quorum 75% des
suffrages lorsque les deux tiers des
électeurs n'ont pas voté
eh bien ça ne veut plus dire grand chose
malgré cela la droite avait viré en tête
dans dix cantons ce qui devrait
l'assurer de conserver sa majorité chat
dans le département face à l es la
gauche se prend à rêver
malgré ses divisions
elle est en position dans cinq des six
cantons un bisontin ainsi cabot mesdames
et valentigney sept cantons potentiel
cela commence à peser enfin la surprise
du premier tour c'est la très nette
érosion du rassemblement national arrivé
en tête de très peu à audincourt et
votre cour il n'a pu se maintenir que
dans sept cantons au lieu de 14 en 2015
merci stéphanie est tout à l'heure est
maintenant gabriel vous nous emmenez il
y aura prendre la direction de l'yonne
un l'yonne où la majorité sortante de
droit de posséder 19 cantons avant cette
élection elle est justement en duel dans
19 cantons pour ce second tour on va
retrouver sur place sébastien kerrous et
bastia ce que vous avez déjà des
premiers éléments sur les résultats de
ce soir est bien ce que je peux vous
dire ce soir c'est que à l'heure
actuelle on ne devrait pas assister à un
renversement de la situation conseil
départemental de l'yonne la droite
semble confirmer ces bons résultats du
premier tour elle est pour l'instant en
tête dans la plupart des cantons 73% à
chablis pour le président sortant du
conseil départemental patrick gendraud
par exemple et puis c'est une
information importante ce soir c'est une
mauvaise soirée pour le rassemblement
national puisqu'il ne remporteraient
pour l'instant aucun canton dans les dix
dans lesquelles il était qualifié
et quant à la gauche elle est pour
l'instant en tête je dis bien pour
l'instant car les résultats ne sont que
partielles à joigny devant le
rassemblement national voilà tous ces
résultats ne sont pour l'instant que
partiel mais la majorité départementale
sortante semble en bonne voie pour
remporter cette élection dans l'yonne
voilà la saône et loire + l'yonne et on
l'a vu de majorité qui semble conforter
mais a précisé plus tard dans la forêt
juste avant de rendre l'antenne à notre
studio pour les élections régionales je
vous rappelle donc eric oberlé le maire
de bavilliers a perdu son canton il
était conseiller départemental sortant
et voilà donc un canton qui bascule de
droite à gauche mais la majorité ne
semble pas forcément la majorité de
droite forcément en danger puisque on me
signale également que le canton de
giromagny passe lui de gauche à droite
on aura plus de résultats tout à l'heure
et on pourra voir les choses
manière beaucoup plus fine à tout à
l'heure et za merci katrina tout à
l'heure jean marie sermier je me tourne
vers vous c'est le retour de la de la
gauche et de la droite classique ce soir
écoutez il faut regarder les chiffres
les résultats définitifs mais
effectivement on a une bipolarisation
avec des arguments très précis la gauche
chez les verts
quelquefois vers excessifs les pervers
comme certains diront et puis il droite
rassemblée qui va effectivement d'une
droite souverainiste à une droite
centriste et donc je crois qu'il ya des
fois des positions qui sont
diamétralement opposées après fou et
plérin sur des collectivités on a aussi
les moyens de se rassembler sur des
dossiers techniques sur des projets mais
moi j'attends c'est à dire que vous ne
serez pas forcément dans l'opposition
systématique
je n'ai jamais été moi je je je suis
effectivement avec des convictions sur
le fait qu'il faut il faut sur nos
territoires
avoir un aménagement du territoire qui
permet à la ruralité qui aujourd'hui est
en grande difficulté de pouvoir s'en
sortir
je crois que les infrastructures de
communication sont essentiels pour notre
région
je crois qu'il faut arrêter de
d'augmenter les impôts même si la région
n'a plus aujourd'hui de beaucoup de
marge mais elle en a encore une c'est
l'écart de grease je crois qu'il faut
arrêter l'endettement dans un certain
nombre de collectivités
voilà c'est des choses sur lequel je
crois mais à partir du moment où il y
aura des propositions qui seront utiles
aux bourguignons et au franc comtois
pour ce qui me concerne mais je pense
parler au nom de mes collègues de droite
et du centre on sera force de
proposition
on sera le premier groupe d'opposition
visiblement et on sera aussi force de
propositions laëtitia martinez
on l'a vu ce soir tous les sortants 2
socialistes sont réélus comme tous les
sortants de droite d'ailleurs
est ce que c'est une sorte de
renaissance pour le ps est ce qu'il y a
des conséquences nationales à tirer de
ces élections locales ce qui est sûr
c'est que l'ancrage de nos territoires
l'ancrage de collectivités à gauche il
existe il a tenu bon malgré les coups de
tempête à certains à certains moments et
on voit bien ce soir on l'a vu aussi à
certains égards aux municipales ce soit
la réélection chez moi au creusot là
encore aujourd'hui à marie-guite dufay
et à près de 55% chez moi dans cette
dans cette ville de saône et loire
je crois que les élus locaux sur les
territoires que connaissent aussi nos
concitoyennes et nos concitoyens qui
mènent des politiques claires en
l'occurrence qui nous concerne les
politiques de gauche sont le fondement
le terreau sur lequel s'appuyait bien
sûr pour pouvoir travailler et porter
ces valeurs sûres des comment dire sur
des projets nationaux et on peut aussi
bien sûr s'appuyer sur tout ce qui se
fait et ce qui se réalise sur nos
territoires qui sont des formidables
champ d'expérimentation aussi pour
pouvoir dans un second temps déployer et
encore une fois transformé ses
propositions à une chaîne nationale
néanmoins on le voit il ya de moins en
moins de candidats qui affichent leur
appartenance partisane on a beaucoup de
divers gauche divers droite divers
centres ce soir la prime au sortant est
très importante partout en france aussi
bien aux départementales que régionales
c'est la victoire du parti socialiste ce
soit en bourgogne franche comté où c'est
la victoire de marie guite dufay
c'est la victoire de marie dit du fait
de la gauche de l'ensemble de la gauche
croit que vous êtes certains n'avaient
pas le logo des partis politiques sur
leur bulletin de vote c'est absolument
pas notre cas chez nous les choses
étaient extrêmement clair depuis le
début les logos de nos partenaires ont
figuré dès le premier instant sur
l'ensemble de nos de nos documents et
depuis le début de cette campagne
marie-guite dufay a appelé au
rassemblement de la gauche donc je crois
que cette pause de ce positionnement
extrêmement clair sur qui nous sommes
qu'elles sont nos convictions
le programme également le travail qui a
été engagée aussi bien sous le précédent
mandat que les propositions qui ont été
faites sont autant de d'éléments je
dirais
constructif qui ont permis aussi
d'amener les électrices et les électeurs
de gauche aux urnes rémy rebeyrotte on
voit la droite et la gauche tirent leur
épingle du jeu ce soir l'ancien monde
n'est pas mort c'était pourtant le
souhait des manuels macron c'est un pari
raté
non moi je dirais d'abord laëtitia
martinez rappelle la reconquête l'an
passé du creusot par une alliance entre
le ps et les marcheurs et sans les
communistes pour vous dire la clarté du
propos donc moi je voudrais simplement
dire les choses telles qu'elles sont je
laisserai les uns des autres gérer leur
extrême nous c'est clair notre discours
notre propos par exemple il est européen
je suis pas certain que dans les autres
quand on soit tous sur la même logique
quand on parle d'europe je suis pas
certain quelqu'un saurait sur la même
logique quand on parle de la relance
nous au moins c'est clair quelle place
aux aurait dans l'hémicyle est pas nous
serons à notre place
qu'est ce que vous voulez touche je vous
réponds qu'il n'est pas question qu'ils
allaient dire nous nous tiendrons nos
sièges croyez moi que quand nous y
sommes et du nous les tenons et voilà
maintenant des peuples d'abord attendons
d'avoir le résultat définitif
et moi je ne suis pas de ceux qui va
vous dire ce soir si nous serons ici ou
là rémy rêve énorme vous parler de ce
que nous sommes vous parlera du mal
effectivement à travailler avec
l'extrême gauche avec une partie des
verts qui n'est pas tout les verts mais
à une partie et en bourgogne franche
comté effectivement on a quelques cas où
on a dix fois du mal à faire la
distinction avec l'extrême gauche
bon on verra mais c'est vrai que yahia
j'allais dire sur la manière dont nous
concevons des grands projets qui doivent
être portées en bourgogne franche comté
qui font l'objet régulièrement d'
attaques sévères de la part des verts
encore récemment la route centre europe
atlantique où il faudra arrêter des
travaux on verra moi je je je demande à
ce que l'on voit comment effectivement
les choses vont se comporter
il ya des alliances qui pèse il ya des
accords qui co
on verra comment ils sont tenus ou pas
laëtitia martinez souhaité répondre
en tout cas ce qu'on constate c'est ce
que vous avez à jouer agité pendant
cette semaine d'entre deux tours sur le
péril vert ou loue le péril rouge
on voit bien quelle est la réponse si
encore une fois les tendances se
confirment
la réponse des urnes ce soir est-ce
qu'il ya pas vous parliez de clarté rémy
rebeyrotte
est ce que au final où vous avez pas un
peu perdu vos électeurs en vous alliant
un coup avec la droite un coup avec la
gauche
la quel niveau vous libère tous les
niveaux non c'est ailleurs que selon les
régions les alliances sont très
différentes et on ne sait plus
finalement où habite la république en
marchant nous essayons dé talent y ait
des gens qui partagent les mêmes valeurs
que nous voilà c'était très clair
notamment sur la question je parle
européenne m'excuserai mais les régions
sa chère quand même les fonds européens
c'est une relation extrêmement
particulière avec l'europe je vous
propose un cas très précis rémy
rebeyrotte la république en marche a
soutenu la liste de jean marie sermier à
dole aux municipales l'an passé mais
nous étions avec nous nous étions avec
david marty au creusot l'an passé et
d'ailleurs à cette occasion là il a mis
de côté l'extrême et vous comprenez que
ce soit difficilement compréhensible
pour les électeurs nous ne changeons pas
nous appelons j'allais dire ceux qui
partagent les mêmes valeurs à travailler
avec nous bon là j'ai observé pas plus
tard que dimanche dernier que nous
avions été littéralement méprisé par
marie-guite dufay s'était d'ailleurs sur
votre plateau françois patriat à votre
place non content revient d'ailleurs
toujours pas bon au profit d'une
alliance qui était pas le cas l'an passé
d'ailleurs mais une alliance avec
l'extrême gauche et avec les verts les
valises que le même champ soit pas de
ria j'irai avec les communistes quand il
était président du conseil régional de
bourgogne
oui avant la fusion oui il s'est passé
un certain nombre de choses positives
dans notre pays depuis un certain nombre
d'années et notamment l'année 2010 est à
marquer quand même à tournan faudrait-il
saints martyrs mais excusez moi mais une
alliance avec les communistes qui
préexistait déjà au moment de
de votre main tendue donc ya pas eu une
entame en de surprise une alliance avec
les verts qui a toujours été annoncée
par la présidente de région cherchant le
rassemblement de toute la gauche
donc encore une fois je suis surprise et
par ailleurs en profite pour rappeler
aux étés c'est un mal à refermer son art
à vous couper la parole par bach
donnez-moi priorité au direct vois pas
partir tout de suite à besançon dans un
hôtel de besançon où julien odoul la
tête de liste du rassemblement national
doit prendre la parole d'un instant à
l'autre on va écouter julian du jeu la
mettre au sol je la pose ou à des
gloires et ça devrait commencer
julian double crédité de 23 7% des
suffrages à cette heure-ci jérémy et
23,7 il serait troisième donc de ce
second tour derrière marie-guite dufay
42,5 derrière gilles platret 24,4 un
très faible écart derrière la droite
mais il faut rappeler qu'en 2015 c'était
déjà le cas
sophie montel était arrivé en tête du
premier tour mais avait été remis ni
troisième du second tour juste derrière
à l'époque la liste menée par françois
sauvadet
mesdames et messieurs les résultats qui
sortent des urnes pour ce second tour
des élections régionales sont une
formidable défaite pour notre démocratie
formidable défaite pour nos institutions
formidable victoire pour l'ensemble des
sortants de france et navarre qui sont
tous réélus et plébiscité ce second tour
a montré une nouvelle fois que notre
démocratie est malade
notre démocratie est à bout de souffle à
bout de souffle car elle a été émis et
est depuis trente à quarante ans par des
politiques qui n'ont pas su entendre nos
concitoyens qui n'ont pas su renouveler
nos institutions qui n'ont pas su faire
en sorte que ces institutions soient
réellement représentative
il y a aujourd'hui une réelle crise de
la démocratie
une désaffection un désenchantement qui
est palpable que nous avons tous entendu
au cours de cette campagne car les
raisons évidemment de cette désaffection
sont multiples la crise sanitaire
problèmes de communication manque de
lisibilité distribution déficiente des
professions de foi manque d'information
est tout simplement de communication du
gouvernement alors qu'il s'était engagé
au début de la crise sanitaire les
reports multiples de ces deux scrutins
qui pour bon nombre de nos concitoyens
apparaissait comme illisible voir
qu'inutile tout cela évidemment doit
nous interpeller tous collectivement ne
pouvons pas nous satisfaire de ce tel
taux d'abstention qui est dramatique qui
est extrêmement inquiétant beaucoup de
nos compatriotes aussi considère à tort
mais considère que les élections
intermédiaires
aujourd'hui ne permettent pas de changer
la situation dans notre pays
beaucoup de nos concitoyens et notamment
les catégories les plus populaires
considère aussi que le seul changement
le la seule lueur d'espoir la seule
possibilité de redressement pour notre
peuple et notre nation réside dans
l'élection présidentielle julien odile
qui est en train de s'exprimer dans son
qg bisontin julian d'août qui sera sur
notre plateau tout à l'heure je vous
propose d'écouter une réaction celle de
denis thuriau la tête de liste la
république en marche jeunes iturrioz qui
s'est exprimée lire quelques minutes aux
biens au micro de vincent collet on
écoute tout d'abord le constat que
l'électorat se mobilise et un peu mieux
mais ya pas eu d lectorat suffisamment
mobilisée pour changer la donne au
deuxième tour par contre la satisfaction
c'est que le rassemblement national
progresse pas ou peu on n'a pas encore
les chiffres définitifs et manifestement
nulle part les français n'en veulent
donc je me réjouis parce que vous savez
c'était mon combat et canton
justement de rester justement second
tour pour faire gagner rassemblement
national je pense que mon choix était le
bon et qu au contraire je le redis si je
m'étais retiré il ya forcément des gens
qui ne seraient pas allés voter et qui
aurait fait monter le rassemblement
national
ça c'est le point positif après
manifestement voilà c'est une élection
qui n'intéresse pas voilà qui n'a pas
davantage intéressée au second tour donc
va vraiment falloir réfléchir à des
réformes
et puis le constat que je fais c'est
qu'il ya une prime aux sortants puisque
ce offert à tous les présidents sortants
sont réélus donc finalement les français
n'ont pas pour ceux qui ont voté que je
remercie donc pas voulu changer voilà
road excusé nouveau retour sur le
plateau quand nous ne sommes pas à
l'antenne ma voisine mais crient dessus
voilà dominique bourgois on a entendu
julien votre tête de liste qui parlait
d'une défaite ce soir pour la démocratie
pour les institutions le fait est que
c'est d'abord votre parti qui souffre de
cette hausse de l'abstention finalement
on a l'impression que les gens qui les
électeurs qui d'ordinaire voulait
s'opposer au système le faisait en
votant rassemblement national
aujourd'hui il s'oppose au système en
restant chez eux partagent pas cette
analyse je pense que les les électeurs
du rassemblement national savent se
mobiliser pour des temps majeur de la
vie démocratique française
les résultats qui apparaissent
aujourd'hui ne préfigure en rien ce qui
pourrait se passer pour les élections
présidentielles de l'année prochaine
aucunement donc il ya vous êtes sûr de
ça on en repart ce que c'est quand même
c'est quand même une grosse défaite pour
le rassemblement national
on en reparlera non je ne pense pas à
mon espoir que vous affichiez alors la
défaite en considération désespoir
évidemment mais
d'un point de vue objectif qu'il a été
rappelé que le rassemblement national
front national en 2015 avait occupé la
3ème position au sein du conseil
régional ce qui sera encore le cas et
comme ça a été rappelé par mon voisin
nous aurons nous aussi sans aucun doute
une une opposition constructive
respectueuse et constructive
parce que j'entends aussi parlé de la
bipolarisation le retour de la
bipolarisation de la vie politique
française droite à gauche mais on a
affaire à des à des groupes gauche
composite droite réformer puisqu'elle va
chasser sur d'autres terres nous sommes
le seul parti de france à avoir une
certaine une personnalité unique
j'allais dire et nous sommes installés
par ailleurs je pense durablement dans
la vie publique
raison pour laquelle nous suscitons à la
fois des inquiétudes et en même temps
parfois des attentes aussi merci je vous
propose qu'on poursuive cette discussion
dans quelques minutes on va tout de
suite faire un deuxième poids sur les
élections départementales
c'est à vos catherine merci merci et ça
je vais tout de suite passé la parole à
gabrielle talon qui va nous conduire
dans la nièvre
oui dans un instant va retrouver un rémy
shiden à nevers mais juste avant un
premier résultat significatif de cette
soirée celui du canton de nevers 3 un
canton qui étaient 2 détenu jusque là
par la droite et qui passa ghost avec
l'élection notamment de l'écologiste
wilfrid séjeau qui l'emportent
c'est très serré à d'à peine trente six
voix on va retrouver rémy qui donne à la
préfecture à nevers fémicide être que
vous avez des premiers éléments des
premières informations sur les résultats
de ce soir est à ce que la gauche peut
déjà être rassuré alors déjà rassuré pas
encore pour l'instant les choses se
présentent bien pour la majorité
sortante dans les trois cantons dont les
résultats sont définitifs devant à la
gauche et une pour la liste est un
canton pour la liste d'opposition suisse
qui ce qui signifie qu à tisser ce
canton de nevers 3 qui était inconstant
crucial détenues par la droite qui
bascule donc à gauche ce soir
la gauche qui à l'issue du premier tour
était en tête dans dix cantons sur 17
si les écarts se maintiennent ce soir ce
serait le même résultat qu'en 2015 pour
les socialistes et leurs alliés mais
pourtant l'opposition ne s'avoue pas
encore battu et reste dans la course
les votes étaient serrés dans plusieurs
cantons à l'issue du premier tour et
certains reports de voix pourrait être
penché en faveur de la liste regroupant
droite centre et lrm et 7 à un duel qui
décidera du aussi du nom du prochain
président du conseil départemental jean
luc bazin pour la gauche
pardon fabien bazin pour la gauche ou
jean-luc gauthier pour la liste de
droite centre et alejo m
qui succèdera donc à la nation voilà
vous l'avez compris le pôle un stand de
canto pour lagos un pour la droite mais
un chip et à la droite par la gauche je
vous propose de partir en haute saône
plus exactement à vesoul où est la
préfecture nous attend yves krattinger
mais avant d'entendre yves krattinger je
vous donne le résultat de villersexel
puisque ce canton bascule de gauche à
droite isabelle géa michel rech
richard lente ou les deux lr l'emportent
très largement avec plus de 54% des voix
yves krattinger est ce que vous nous
entendez bien oui bonjour yves
krattinger donc le seul résultat que
j'ai pour le moment ces séries de
villersexel un canton que vous président
divers gauche de ce département perdre
et avec quels sont les autres résultats
que vous avez c'est russie
catastrophique partout où vous en
conserver g dans votre majorité
je crois pouvoir dire à l'heure qu'il
est que nous avons toujours une majorité
oui que nous avons remporté la victoire
dans dix cantons sur 17
donc on n'avons perdu qu'un d'après lui
l'information dont je dispose d'autre
part je n'ai pas d'info sur le bassin
julien où étaient en lice celui qui
s'était déclarée comme mon adversaire
privilégié il faut que je fasse une
petite explication de texte là parce
qu'on a on n'est pas juste entre nous il
ya des gens qui regardent et qui sont
pas forcément au courant
la petite pique que vous en voyez c'est
une pique en direction dallage voyant
des qui est le sénateur lr2 outox est
également conseiller régional sortant
qui se représente est et il avait décidé
de se présenter sur un canton de vesoul
et il avait dit que la droite prendrait
le département et qu'il vous prendrai
par la même occasion votre place de
président du conseil départemental de
haute saône d'après vous il est en
mauvaise posture
déjà sur le canton je viens de vous dire
que je suis en situation de rassembler
une majorité sur les cantons où nous
étions déjà sortant sauf paul hertz
excellent donc je ne suis pas inquiet
sur le résultat global
c'est les résultats canton par canton
donc je ne peux que me réjouir de
remporter avec l'équipe qui m'entoure
une nouvelle victoire merci beaucoup
monsieur krattinger merci donc à vous
gabriel nous allons dans l'yonne cette
fois ci alors pas tout de suite
catherine on va d'abord pas fait sarlat
peines quel suspense on va d'abord
passer par la côte-d'or et par dijon la
côte d'or qui avait déjà il ya du binôme
au premier tour tous deux de la majorité
sortante de droite dont le président
françois sauvadet d'espagne berger
absolument gabriel et puis on va voir un
effectivement si cette élection dès
dimanche dernier 2 françois sauvadet le
président sortant est de bonne augure
pour la majorité départementale qui
détenait quatorze cantons sur 23 un
avantage numérique qui pourrait se
réduire ce soir puisque des bascules
sont très possible à gauche comme à
droite
même si comme partout la prime au
sortant a très bien fonctionné et ça
semble être le cas
d'après les tout premiers résultats de
ce deuxième tour pas de suspense dans
les quatre cantons où les élus de la
majorité sortante affrontait des
candidats du rassemblement national à
beaune pas de suspense non plus puisque
c'était un duel gauche droite
par contre des cantons sont
particulièrement incertains dans la
métropole dijonnaise et sur dix jours
même avec une situation beaucoup plus
tendue qu'en 2015 dans les deux cantons
sur six encore détenus par la majorité
départementale en particulier 10 juin un
canton considéré comme un bastion de
droite imprenable jusqu'à présent
voilà une situation tendue vous le voyez
catherine ya comme un peu de suspense
dans cette soirée et oui il y en a même
beaucoup
d'ailleurs on reviendra tout à l'heure
pour vous dire justement les cantons qui
basculent et ceux qui restent dans leur
camp à tout à l'heure tu as l'air
catherine merci et stéphanie modde ex
tête de liste d'europe écologie les
verts désormais quatrième sur la liste
de marie-guite dufay dans le département
de côte-d'or nous a rejoint bonsoir à
vous est ce que vous êtes entièrement
satisfait de ce soir de la victoire de
marie-guite dufay
je suis satisfaite parce que nous depuis
le début donc nous avions fait le choix
d'être sur une liste du pôle écologiste
au premier tour avec un résultat plus de
10% ce qui permet vraiment d'encre est
l'écologie politique le projet
écologiste dans notre région comme dans
l'ensemble ailleurs des régions où le
vote écologiste progresse est donc
centré dans les territoires et puis
après effectivement comme ça a déjà été
dit nous avions de toute façon envisagée
si les conditions le permettaient de
rejoindre et de fusionner avec la main
via liste marie-guite dufay
cette fusion a permis de faire un score
bien élevé même qui dépasse les 40% je
crois si on accumule les trois listes de
gauche et des écologistes d'ailleurs je
salue aussi le temps des cerises qui
leur voix aussi porter pour cette
élection de second tour
ce que je constate c'est que malgré je
lui dirai les propos parfois absolument
diffamant qu'a tenu à droite et la
droite extrême à l'encontre des
écologistes à l'encontre des soixante
sept mille électeurs qui nous ont fait
confiance au 1er tour vous parlez de
petites phrases les khmers verts n'y a
pas eu que ça ça a été continuellement
les khmers verts les extrémistes ne sais
quoi je n'ai pas changé en une semaine
ne vous êtes pas que sans abri l'entente
avec des valeurs ancrées à gauche et je
dirais d'ailleurs hauts représentants de
la république en marche effectivement
contrairement à la république en marge
du jeu si tu je sais encore différencier
ma main gauche de ma main droite
donc moi je suis entré à gauche les des
valeurs humanistes et des valeurs de
valeurs sociales de justice sociale que
n'ont pas les listes de droit voilà ça
c'est mon constat donc à partir de là
moi je
je suis effectivement satisfaite donc
nous aurions espéré effectivement peser
un peu plus dans cet hémicycle mais nous
serons là pour vraiment en craie
l'écologie et surtout vraiment c'est
pourquoi nous avons vraiment tenu à
cette fusion c'est parce qu'il ya une
chose qui n'attend pas ces dérèglements
climatiques ce dernier mais mur
litigieux on aurait aimé peser davantage
on sait que les négociations avec le
parti socialiste ont été très compliqué
vous demandez une quinzaine d'élus c'est
à dire une fusion à la proportionnelle
finalement vous n'en avez obtenu que 8
est-ce que d'ores et déjà avant même de
débuter
le lycée du avec un programme est ce qu
avant même de débuter le mandingue l'eau
dans le gaz pendant les périodes yoga
socialiste obtenu un programme et nous
serons peser les huit élus avec beaucoup
de loyauté que nous attendons d'ailleurs
de façon réciproque et bien évidemment
dans une majorité où nous aurons toute
notre place il nous serons aussi tenir
mais nous avons un programme que nous
avons défini ensemble qui est avec
quelques points de divergence mais
énormément de convergence il n'y aura
pas de souci il verrait ça va bien se
passer et c'est surtout que l'enjeu
majeur de cette de ses deux mandats je
le répète c'est la justice sociale et
c'est la transition écologique
énergétique et c'est là l'attend pas
nous ferons tout pour peser et nous
ferons tout pour que ça se passe bien
pour que nous puissions tous avancer
ensemble la majorité réunis laëtitia
martinez beaucoup de tractations
détention aussi cette semaine avec les
verts est-ce que cet épisode va laisser
des traces ou pas du tout je crois que
dans tout
à ce moment là d'une élection il ya des
échanges qui me paraissent mois à c'est
assez naturel et qui ne sont en plus que
la la continuité des choses qui se sont
qui se sont tenus encore une fois
puisque cette perspective de la de
rassemblement nous la souhaitions depuis
depuis le départ et je crois que ce que
tu es ce que stéphanie me vient
d'évoquer me semble extrêmement
important c'est à dire ce sur quoi
nous rassemblons ses valeurs qui ne sont
pas que de simples de samples principe
puisque c'est justement parce que ces
valeurs là que nous transformons nos
politiques publiques que nous leur
donnons cette teinte de gauche c'est ça
notre identité politique la justice
sociale je crois que nous l'avons
démontré pendant ce mandat nous l'avons
mise en oeuvre dans de nombreuses
politiques publiques je pense aux
tarifications dans les cantines les
bears dedans à l'internât et c est le
maintien de tous et budget sport enfin
je suis ancien jusque là vice présidente
aux sports la bourgogne franche comté le
maintien de ses budgets et l'importance
que nous avons consacré à la fraternité
qui est en nous prenons souvent
marie-guite dufay
je crois que ce sont sur ces valeurs là
que nous nous retrouvons et que ça nous
donne un socle très solide pour pouvoir
développer le programme vos adversaires
disent que vous serez otage d'une
minorité verte ou d'une minorité
communiste
qu'est ce que vous répondez à ça je
crois que nos adversaires cherchent nous
comment dire cherche à mettre en place
des des failles qui n'existe pas je
crois qu'ils cherchent aussi à ne pas
parler des résultats de ce soir qui sont
avant tout encore une fois avec la
précaution de des résultats des
résultats définitifs
mais si ça se confirme on est quand même
à quasiment 20 points devant le deuxième
de cette de cette élection je crois que
le sujet de ce soir
il est il est là et maintenant c'est
comment on va continuer le travail qu'on
a engagé ces cinq dernières années pour
l'ensemble des habitantes et les
habitants de bourgogne franche comté
jean marie sermier ce que vous êtes
rassurés parce que vous venez d'entendre
loyauté absolument pas parce que c'est
ce qu'on a entendu pendant le début de
campagne où il y avait deux listes et où
nous expliquer que c'était clair et
comme vous l'avez rappelé la négociation
s'est fait dans la difficulté
donc aujourd'hui ce qui est important
c'est certes d'avoir gagné demain ce qui
sera important c'est délire même du fait
mais ce que nous attendons nous c'est la
gestion pendant toutes les années à
venir 2 3 millions d'habitants de 2
milliards de budget sur lequel il faudra
vraiment travailler en rassemblement et
moody's ont réussi à je ne souhaite pas
vrai que j'ai rassemblé en une
adversaire que la droite
région de france à perdre des habitants
je crois qu'il ya des marqueurs
importants comme ça donc il faut faire
attention je ne souhaite pas que nous
soyons une région qu'ils soient
couvertes pour ses collines de toutes
les éoliennes qu'on peut imaginer
donc voilà je pense qu'il ya des sujets
sur lesquels on aura l'occasion de voir
comment madame du fai va va s'orienter
stéphanie modde sourit oui ce soir ce
que je skie esquerré elle sait que les
francs comtois bourguignons ne veulent
plus entendre parler de division ne
veulent plus entendre parler qui de gens
qui oppose les uns aux autres et les
résultats des trois listes de droite de
la droite extrême prouve bien que vous
n'avez pas réussi à rassembler vos quand
déjà première chose et que vous avez
cessé pendant cette cette semaine entre
les deux tours de dire ce qui
éventuellement ne pourrait ne pas aller
nous avons un véritable projet que nous
allons construire ensemble
donc de grâce ayez la défaite je dirais
à peu près correct est sensé et laissez
nous travailler puisque c'est nous qui
aurons la gauche rassembler les
écologistes la région et donc nous
ferons le travail et ne vous inquiétez
pas tout va bien se passer
stéphanie modde on a beaucoup parlé des
postes mais qu'est-ce que sur le projet
les verts ont amené dans le projet de
marie-guite dufay juridique est un enjeu
très très fort c'est la transition
écologique transition énergétique
la question de l'eau la question de
l'environnement de la forêt du climat et
ça ça n'attend pas et marie-guite dufay
tout à fait d'accord nous sommes
vraiment tombés d'accord sur le fait
qu'il faut avancer vite en embarquant
tout le monde parce que c'est important
effectivement que tout le monde
maintenant il ya une conscience qui est
là maintenant il faut vraiment souffert
montrer que nous pouvons tous ensemble
on parlait de l'europe de l'europe à la
france jusqu'aux régions dire qu'il sait
maintenant qu'il faut agir et c'est
vraiment la raison d'être encore une
fois de ma liste des écologistes pour
ces élections
il faut vraiment que nous puissions
avancer maintenant rapidement pour
juguler cette effets du dérèglement
climatique
rémy rebeyrotte est-ce que même question
que cas jean marie sermier vous êtes
rassurés par les mots qui ont été
prononcés ce soir par différentes
composantes de la future majorité à moi
je veux féliciter
europe ecologie les verts parce qu ils
ont tenu un accord qui est très
engageant pour la suite et qui
m'inquiète énormément
donc si vous voulez je ne peux pas je ne
peux pas notre voisine de gauche firme
les ou lève les yeux aussi alors décidé
ne pas vous féliciter pour sa part
contre par contre je pense que la
transition écologique n'est pas
seulement ne doit pas seulement porté
par la gauche et l'extrême gauche mais
est un enjeu si tu aimes est un an est
un enjeu absolument majeur je pense
qu'une partie
c'est nous qui avons pris l'initiative
pour la liste de la convention c'est
nous qui avons pris l'initiative
oui de la convention citoyenne madère et
nous avons une loi qui est ambitieux non
pas dans la transition écologique mais
vous n'êtes vous avez un avis yeux pour
s'enliser la gauche de trouver tout ce
n'est pas à l'extrême gauche de la rance
et n'est jamais suffisant ils s'aiment
pas il faudrait son jour aller vers le
grand soir est la grande rupture et bien
et nous nous n'y sommes noirs des
comptes parce que si vous voulez même
faute mais prie madame jaillira vous
avez fait un peu plus de 10% à peu moins
que nous au premier tour je n'ai rien
dit là-dessus madame je voudrais
simplement dire que l'apport que vous
avez passé sur le fond magnette
eh bien écoutez en tout cas c'est pas le
c'est pas les 40 même 42% des électeurs
qui ont choisi la liste de rassemblement
et des écologistes et de la gauche unie
et rassemblée
il y à l'encontre et qui gagnent en
totale faut qu'on refasse un moyen sur
les départementales voilà merci on
poursuit la discussion juste après tout
de suite on retrouve 4e série à cabrer
talent oui donc ici nous allons tout de
suite donné la parole à à gabriel oui et
pour tout d'abord regardé ce résultat en
saône et loire celui du canton de cergy
à canton qui étaient détenues par la
gauche et par la première fédéral du
parti socialiste vieux le nous il est
elle a finalement battu le canton
bascule à droite on vous le disait un la
saône et loire c'était une majorité
sortante de droite un département qui
avait basculé il ya six ans on va tout
de suite prendre la direction de mâcon
où on doit retrouver normalement andré
accary bonsoir bonsoir
je le disais à symboliquement c'est un
moment assez fort la bascule de ce
canton de gergy vous partie avec vous
aviez gagné c'est ce canton il y a 6 ans
on a l'impression que vous n'avez encore
creuser votre majorité cette année de
quels résultats disposez-vous pour
l'instant sans doute les mêmes résultats
que vous mais vraisemblement où il a la
majorité de de la saône et loire va se
renforcer puisque plusieurs cantons sont
en train de basculer de gauche à droite
vous en avez cité un oeil en a un autre
je crois sur l'uriné et puis d'autres se
profilent vraisemblablement donc donc
pour l'instant
aujourd'hui vous allez certainement home
et les bonnes nouvelles arrivent vous
allez certainement accentué votre
majorité vous une grande victoire pour
vous ce soir où je ne parlerai de deux
victoires quand quand j'aurai les les
résultats officiels bien sûr mais pour
l'instant c'est vrai que la tendance est
bonne et j'en suis ma foi bien
bienheureux pas que pour moi pour
l'équipe qui m'entoure évidemment et
puis une nouvelle fois je voudrais
remercier déjà tous ceux qui ont
participé au scrutin notamment je pense
à tous ceux qui ont tenu les bureaux de
vote aujourd'hui dans des conditions qui
ne sont pas tout à fait facile donc en
tout cas voilà je mets venait à
remercier déjà une première fleur de la
cave immersive aux cadres hakkari qui
aurait été chercher un petit peu cette
large majorité plutôt au centre puisque
deux binômes de boucher lui avait choisi
de le rejoindre dont dominique lotte qui
accueille on se représente est née cette
fois pour la pour la majorité sortante
de droite et vous allez le voir sur ce
résultat malgré le changement
d'étiquette
il a été réélu voilà ce qui illustre
bien ce qui se passe actuellement
catherine en saône et loire
alors moi je vais donc vous proposer
d'aller maintenant à belfort vous nous
retrouvons donc florian bouquet qui est
le président du lr les républicains du
conseil départemental en sachant que
bavilliers bascule de droite à gauche et
que giromagny fait le chemin inverse de
gauche à droite florian bouquet et votre
majorité est totalement conforté ce soir
vous êtes encore en difficulté
ajoute donc vous vous avez été élu dès
le premier tour et que messieurs boukaré
perrin sont élus également
alors où en est on c'est exactement ça
donc les le sénateur cédric perrin était
lui bien sûr sur le contour de delgo
cours ainsi que le député yanbu car qui
a repris le canton au modem qui a mené
une alliance dans une alliance avec la
république en marche et qui a été
favorable à la majorité départementale
que je préside sur le secteur de
giromagny c'est didier valverde qui a
été élu brillamment qui a repris le
canton à la gauche
donc la majorité départementale que que
je conduis a été largement confirmé
aujourd'hui puisqu'on passe de cinq
cantons à six cantons dans la majorité
d'accord très bien je vous remercie
beaucoup florian bouquet je suis désolé
il faut qu'on rentre tout de suite
l'antenne pour le plateau des régionales
et il nous reste que quelques minutes
donc à vous et elsa a tout de suite
merci beaucoup catherine alors d'après
nos résultats vous l'avez compris à la
majorité présidentielle denis thuriau
réalise un petit peu moins de 10% des
suffrages
on va revivre le début de soirée denis
thuriau tout de suite avec un vincent
collet romani rose à la préfecture de
région la liste de denis thuriau
seraient environ à 10 % des voix en ce
second tour d'après un comptage partiel
ce qui signifie très clairement que la
liste de la majorité présidentielle a
perdu des forces entre les deux tours
elle était dimanche dernier à 11 7% des
suffrages déception donc pour les
maquereaux nist est toute la question ce
soir est de savoir de combien de sièges
ils pourront disposer dans la future
assemblée régionale environ sept ou huit
même s'il est encore beaucoup trop tôt
pour le dire car ce type de calcul est
complexe
une certitude tassement des voix en
faveur de la majorité présidentielle en
ce second tour en bourgogne franche
comté c'est donc la déception qui domine
ici voilà vincent collet en préfecture
et ont parlé de denis thuriau je
voudrais m'adresser à vous rémy
rebeyrotte depuis tout à l'heure vous
pointer les verts en disant qu'ils sont
l'extrême gauche est-ce que c'est à dire
que pour vous ils sont aussi voulait
renvoyer dos à dos avec l'extrême droite
du rassemblement national vous les
mettez dans le même panier non mais moi
je je ne classe pas les extrêmes mais
les deux troncs des extrêmes vous mais
je ne jeûne n'y appartiens pas ni d'un
côté ni de l'autre et nous ne souhaitons
pas aller dire par définition même
d'ailleurs la république en marche
ce sont des gens de centre-droit et de
centre gauche qui travaillent ensemble
et qu'ils ont appris à travailler
ensemble
me demandez pas si je classe et comment
je classe des extrêmes pour nous il
s'agit des chats p&g ni de la sympathie
pour le front national
surtout pas pour le rassemblement
national et je le condamne au plus haut
niveau
j'ai pas grande sympathie pour et les
filles dans ses variantes diverses et
variées stéphanie mais je ne suis pas un
défi qu'elle ça vous aurait échappé
julien bayou ne s'appelle pas jean-luc
je sais pas vous dites des choses tout
et son contraire en même temps et on a
même ajustements dont tout à l'heure
vous avez dit mais peu importe
moi j'aurais revenir sur quelque chose
de vraiment important sur ce que nous
allons faire maintenant sur sept sur
sept listes rassemblé plus de justice
sociale rééquilibrage et territoires sur
la partie vous demandiez sur le
programme
c'est beaucoup plus d'argent sur la
biodiversité sixième extinction des 1%
du budget pour cent du budget régional
c'est beaucoup plus de bio et notamment
dans la restauration collective
c'est un vrai budget pour la forêt c'est
aussi un plan de transition vers les
métiers verts parce que nous avons
effectivement besoin que notre région
retiennent les jeunes et de l'emploi
donc voilà c'est la transition aussi
écologique de 2,2 le bio l'industrie des
thématiques vraiment majeur et qui ont
su intéresser les électeurs laëtitia
martinez les amendements des verts à
votre projet initial vous les trouvez
positif bah écoutez il ya eu d'une part
comment dire l'engagement de marie-guite
dufay en faveur de la transition
écologique je crois qu'elle l'a
parfaitement démontré au cours de son de
son précédent mandat est effectivement
aller il s'agit d'aller encore plus loin
sur les questions de biodiversité sur
l'approvisionnement bio et en local 2
de nos cantines qui sont des dynamiques
qui vont effectivement dans le même sens
c'est bien d'ailleurs la raison pour
laquelle on se retrouve sur ce sur ce
second tour alors on va se quitter pour
une quinzaine de minutes avec le plateau
nationale mais avant ça jérémy on va
peut-être donner nos estimations ipsos
et steria l'aï sorti notre partenaire
qui nous donne les résultats de ce
premier tour les premières tendances
marie-guite dufay à la tête d'une liste
d'union de la gauche ps prg pcf europe
ecologie les verts est en tête de ce
second tour elle sera donc réélue
présidente de région avec 42 et demi
pour cent des suffrages
elle devance le républicain gilles
platret qui a obtenu un score de 24,4
puis julien odoul du rassemblement
national 23,7 et enfin denis thuriau la
république en marche le modem à 9 4% ce
sont des estimations la semaine dernière
l'estimation de 20 heures était
quasiment parfaitement fiable donc je
pense qu'on peut se fier à ce que nous
annonce notre partenaire voilà
marie-guite dufay largement réélu ce
soir sa liste largement en tête de ce
second tour en bourgogne franche comté
et ça correspond au premier décompte on
va effectivement prendre tout de suite
la direction du plateau de la rédaction
nationale pour voir ce qui se passe dans
les autres régions et puis ensuite dans
moins de quinze minutes on se retrouve
sur le plateau avec nous on aura denis
thuriau pour la république en marche
gilles platret l air et puis à priori
marie-guite dufay qui devrait s'exprimer
à 10,6 pour une première déclaration
d'ici quelques minutes
a tout de suite elle a tout de suite
merci
[Musique]